who took a bite of this
[Music]
hey i'm kelly and i'm a culinary
producer at tasty and this is my husband
jeremy hi i'm jeremy and i'm a chef
and we have been cooking together for 11
years yeah that sounds about right we
met in culinary school day one he fell
in love i didn't wow
i'm joking we have two wonderful young
boys dylan and teddy and dylan will be
joining us today are you nervous at all
no i feel great
why because you have to pick between
mommy and daddy yeah are there any like
challenge stakes we could add to this if
i win i would love some help with the
laundry um this whole seven loads a week
thing isn't working for me anymore maybe
split it up fine okay so what happens if
i win i'll wake up before 9am
yeah i want to sleep in on the weekends
you got it okay see you
for today's challenge i'm going to be
making a space themed pizza lunch box we
are going to start with easy peasy pizza
dough in a can so i have this cute
rocket shaped cookie cutter i'm going to
cut out a few kind of small i don't know
how i'm going to stop it with pizza all
right let's do one and then assess if i
have to change my game plan so this is
just store-bought pizza sauce again
store-bought is fine
they don't care so i'm just gonna put
like the teeniest little amount and then
i'm gonna add some cheese
and then i found these little baby
pepperonis that i thought were so cute
now i'm just going to egg wash the outer
part the outer like rim so i can stick
another piece on top and glue it
together kind of just looks like a
christmas tree it definitely lost its
shape
that's okay that's okay all right i also
have this
rocket maybe this will look better
okay this one's cute all right so i'm
just gonna brush the top with egg wash
to get it nice and crispy and then i was
just gonna put a little parmesan on top
so it's like half pizza half cheesy
breadstick and then
maybe i should make a little window
okay so i'm gonna bake these at 4 25 i
think for like eight to ten minutes but
we'll see i wanted to recreate those
like little pudding packs but i wanted
to make a healthier version it's called
abc pudding avocado banana and cacao and
then i'm gonna call it galaxy pudding
and dye some whipped cream blue and
purple and swirl it on top so it's like
outer space theme but a little bit
healthier first thing a is avocado i
could not find any good avocados at the
store so i actually found these frozen
ones so they look pretty green so we're
going to add those in and we'll probably
give it like a nice texture that it's
frozen add one banana
and then the c is cocoa powder which is
where the chocolate comes in
dylan has the biggest sweet tooth he
asks for cookies and cake every morning
i have to tell him that's not a
breakfast food so i think he'll be
really excited about this and then just
to sweeten it up i'm gonna add some
maple syrup
i'm gonna add a little bit of milk just
to like help it blend together and then
how we do that we're gonna blend it up
that's perfect he is gonna love this
this might be my winning star the next
step i'm gonna do for my lunch box is
add some fruit and veggies just to add
some balance to the pizza and the
pudding i'm just going to cut some thick
slices
and then take my star cookie cutter
look how cute then for the bell pepper i
was actually thinking it could be like
the like the fire the gas what is it so
i'm just gonna cut it in thin strips and
then maybe in half
and then like here's the rocket chip and
then i'll put them underneath like that
carrots too dylan loves carrots and
hummus so we got our veggies now let's
move on to the fruit
look how juicy that is first i'm just
gonna cut some circles i mean i guess
it's a full moon but maybe i should make
it a little cuter
cute okay i wanted to create some type
of martian alien to go with the space
theme so i found this little cheese and
i'm gonna pull the wax off
and then cut it down the middle
and then i'm going to use some
marshmallow fluff to glue on some eyes
kind of like the toy story martian
i've never done this but we'll see i
just have to tell dylan he can't eat the
wax i don't know do they look like
aliens
maybe maybe if i can like put some
toothpicks in his head so i need to make
a planet and green is his favorite color
so i'm going to take a tootsie roll
lollipop and put a ring around it
to make saturn
that's cute
right
no
to make like the green antennas i'm
going to take some green apple and cut
little strips and then stick it in the
top
it kind of looks like a rabbit
it looks like a three-eyed rabbit let's
just move on what do i have next i gotta
make the ranch dip the best part okay so
we're just gonna put some sour cream and
i'm going old school with the ranch
packet because you cannot beat this
flavor
even as a chef i know i've made ranch a
million times it never
tastes like this ever ever when i worked
in a restaurant and when i was a
waitress i was in charge of making the
ranch people were always asking for the
recipe and everything
is on the back of the package
okay i'll put this in the fridge and
then move on to the next step all right
we're on to the last step i'm gonna make
the galaxy whipped cream to go on to our
healthy pudding so i'm just gonna take
some heavy cream
i'm gonna add just a little bit of
powdered sugar to sweeten it and then
i'm just gonna beat this with a hand
mixer on high speed until medium to 60
those are stiff peaks a little bit of
purple oh this is like a neon purple
this is fun okay so we got purple done
now let's add blue
i was a little bit nervous the food dye
would mess with the texture of the
whipped cream but it's actually it's
working out okay all right and now we're
gonna do the fun part we're gonna go to
the assembly first i'm going to add my
rocket chip
and then i'm gonna add some bell peppers
and some carrots coming off the end so
it looks like it's that fire spurting
out
i have my star cucumbers and then i also
have my mango moons uh with some
blueberries because i know dylan loves
those so now i have my alien martians
we're still not sure about these but
they're cute they're cute okay the best
part are healthy pudding
look at those fun colors he's gonna love
that he's gonna love it and then
for the all-star
i found these outer space themed
sprinkles and finally our little saturn
lollipop and that's it
so today i will be cooking a superhero
themed lunch i will be making a captain
america burrito captain america rice
krispie treats little spiderman
strawberries and the hammers of thor
using cheese and pretzel sticks at home
we call dylan captain america because he
protects his little brother who we call
iron man so i think this one will go
over well with it so first for the rice
krispies treats we're gonna melt some
butter the more fat the better so now
that the butter's melted i'm just gonna
add in the marshmallows
now that our marshmallow and butter are
nice and smooth and all mixed together
we will add the rice krispies
i'm just going to mix it all together
until it all
forms one ball and then we'll get it
cooling down
all right now they're all mixed together
and we'll start cooling them down so we
could shape them into balls and into
shields
so normally if i was going to make rice
krispies treats i would flatten this out
and try to compress it but since we're
just rolling it into balls i'll just pop
it into the fridge like this and let it
cool down now that they're cooled down i
could add some sprinkles if you add them
while they're still warm the color will
bleed into them and you'll just kind of
have a brown mess and then shape them
into balls and shields and now we're
gonna mix the sprinkles into the rice
krispies
now once they're mixed in we're just
gonna roll it into a little ball and
then flatten it out to look like a
shield we're just gonna use a hole
cutter and punch out the center to
represent the star on his shield
so next we are going to make spiderman
faces out of strawberries chocolate
chips and marshmallow fluff so this is
really simple
all we're going to do is slice the
strawberries so now we have our face
next we will place two chocolate chips
as the eyes try to wedge them in there
and then we're going to shape those eyes
with the light to kind of make it look
like spider-man's eyes
[Music]
okay now we have small strawberries that
vaguely look like spider-man
next we're gonna cut cubes out of a
block of cheese
for a thor's hammer and put pretzel
sticks into the box so make it look like
a big hammer so next up i'm going to try
to make the fist of the incredible hulk
the hulk wears purple pants so i'm going
to take vanilla yogurt and purple food
coloring and mix that together and then
use green grapes to form a fist on top
of the purple yogurt
kind of
so next we are going to make our captain
america burrito and since there aren't
many burrito friendly foods that come in
the color blue and we want red white and
blue we're going to add a little bit of
blue food coloring to our mozzarella
cheese i'm going to add a little salsa
to my red beans just to give it a little
more red color and to give it a little
more flavor because dylan does love
salsa the first layer we're gonna add is
the rice and the rice is already white
so we don't have to add any color to
that for the red white and blue theme
after the rice we'll add in our red
beans and then we'll top the whole thing
off with the blue cheese and roll it up
so now that our burrito's rolled we're
just going to sear it off in the pan to
get the cheese nice and melty and the
burrito all sealed up all right now
we're just going to cut into the burrito
and hopefully have red white and blue
for captain america next we're gonna
make little spider webs out of string
cheese to put underneath the
strawberries and then we're gonna
assemble everything and put it into the
box got those with a couple of our
spiderman strawberries next we will pipe
in some hummus into our lightning bolt
mold
and then we'll put the
thor hammers around that now we have our
already assembled hulk hands we're just
going to drop this in here
going to add a little bit of guacamole
for the burrito next we'll add our
burrito
can't forget our captain america dessert
and last
just to keep with the superheroes
we'll add our little guys so he knows
who he's looking at
and this is the superhero lunch
[Music]
strawberry i don't know how to get them
out i got it you see now i want
a potato
[Music]
no
i have the next one
the moon
i take his eyes off
this is a cold rocket ship
what was your favorite thing out of both
of these the strawberries
and
the alien oh the alien do you like that
cheese did you like your pizza i know it
was pizza
because it was cold
some people like cold pizza dough i
don't
all right we have a tough question to
ask you which one was your favorite uh
mommy yay
[Applause]
what made it the best
uh
the lollipop yeah
looks like mommy's sleeping in this
weekend
i forgot and that means you get to help
me with the laundry
no
thanks for having me
[Music]